[Música]
mujeres trans en deportes de mujeres
biológicas sinceramente creo que es caso
por caso porque por qué crees que
debería hacer caso por caso porque no
creo que deban permitirse en los
deportes femeninos Si tuvieras que
clasificarte frente a otros en función
de un rasgo en específico qué diría
sobre cómo los ves y cómo te ven para
averiguarlo reunimos a 5 conservadores y
les pedimos que se clasificaran de menos
a más políticamente de la derecha luego
les pedimos que tomaran la prueba de la
brújula política y los reorganizaran
Esta es la clasificación soy Hunter
trabajo como seguridad Creo en Jesús
realmente no voy a la iglesia pero así
es como me criaron soy un poco más
libertario que autoritario entonces Un
gobierno más pequeño sería mejor soy
Cameron no soy religiosa en absoluto yo
soy agnóstica estuve en el cuerpo de
Marines por cuatro años Estoy muy a
favor de las armas creo que es mi
ecualizador nunca seré tan fuerte como
un hombre pero de solamente tengo mi
derecho a mi segunda enmienda y lo usaré
si es necesario Mi nombre es navni pero
pueden llamarme navi como en la leyenda
de Zelda en cuanto a mis puntos de vista
políticos me describo como conservador
fiscal pero socialmente sigo más una
escuela de pensamiento paleoalimentaria
así que me describiría como muy
constitucionalista apoyo la primera
enmienda la segunda enmienda pero me
consideraría más de la izquierda
apoyándome en otros temas como que soy
ambientalista sin embargo apoyo mucho a
la comunidad lgbt Porque muchos de mis
amigos son parte yo soy parte de eso
para ser más específicos soy bisexual y
por cierto también Es la primera vez que
lo digo públicamente Oh bueno
felicitaciones Mi nombre es Kelly soy de
Nueva York y vivo en Washington DC soy
religiosa soy judía no apoyo a la
comunidad lgbt Por cierto no soy anti
Gami ni nada por el estilo Pero apoyo
los valores tradicionales en el hogar
sin embargo no creo Al 100% que mis
valores religiosos tengan nada que ver
con mis valores conservadores tra
mantener la religión fuera del camino
porque sé que hay conservadores que no
son religiosos soy maui soy originario
de Colorado estoy un poco en un lugar
extraño donde crecí religioso y crecí
muy liberal he estado yendo y viniendo
en muchos temas en cuanto inmigración
porque soy mitad mexicano es extraño
porque el provenir de una familia
mexicana tradicional tienen muchos
valores conservadores pero se etiquetan
a sí mismos como liberales muchas de las
personas negras que conozco y con las
que crecí tienen valores conservadores
pero si les preguntas como por quién vas
a votar siempre va a ser demócrata más
de lo que pase así que es interesante
que lo dijeras porque tengo una conexión
con eso Cuáles creen que son las
tradiciones que tienen los conservadores
me gustan las armas es como pintar con
brocha gorda son cosas de sentido común
creo que apoyar la Constitución estoy de
acuerdo con todas las enmiendas sin
embargo solo la idea general deberías
poder surgir por ti mismo y si te
esfuerzas puedes llegar a donde quieras
estar la belleza de este país sin
importar quien seas claro algunas
personas tienen ciertos factores que lo
harán más fácil lo más difícil para
ellos pero siento que en este país con
la cantidad de oportunidades puede ser
lo que quieras y llegar a donde quieras
estar Esta es una pregunta interesante
No creo que ser conservador tenga nada
que ver con tu una afiliación política
creo que esas cosas están separadas y
creo que mucha gente las confunde
acabamos de hablar sobre cómo la
comunidad negra la India la mexicana
muchos de ellos son conservadores pero
se inclinan hacia la izquierda realmente
creo no me importa lo que hagas en tu
vida eres un adulto no tienes ningún
efecto sobre mí yo no soy religiosa no
fuerzas tus opiniones podemos tener una
discusión estoy muy abierta a tener
diálogos con cualquiera me encanta
conversar algo que está pasando en este
momento es todo esto de las mujeres
trans en los deportes de mujeres
biológicas sinceramente creo que es caso
por caso porque por qué crees que
debería hacer caso por caso porque no
creo que deban permitirse en los
deportes femeninos estoy de acuerdo
contigo no debe ser caso por caso solo
no debería permitirse porque se ha visto
no sé las estadísticas no las recuerdo
pero iluminan las personas que son
biológicamente hombres así que siento
que tratar con absolutos en un sentido
general como que en el discurso político
puede ser algo muy peligroso porque como
él mencionó hay valores atípicos y
siempre tenemos que tenerlos en cuenta y
no estoy seguro de estar de acuerdo con
eso creo que mi diferencia es que no
creo que las mujeres trans sean mujeres
biológicas No seré un idiota si quieres
que Me refiera a ti como ella lo haré te
llamaré por tu nombre Te respetaré como
ser humano está bien ser diferente sí no
entiendo A qué se refieren con valores
atípicos Porque todos son hombres veo
esto como absoluto las mujeres trans no
son mujeres son hombres no me gusta
llamarlo ignorancia eso lo que cada uno
tiene sus puntos de vista y puedo
entenderlo
deberíamos votar democrata totalmente
voy a decir que eres un 5 para mí sí yo
también creo sí no es algo malo y me
moveré hasta la izquierda
uno es lo máximo 5 es lo mismo
estaba pensando en ti de número 3 y tú
de número 2 es por la religión sí creo
que hay dos escuelas de pensamiento con
las que podemos ir la de los valores
tradicionales en las que siento que tú
todavía serías la número uno por como
hablaste cuando los describiste o el
pensamiento político Ya sea que cada uno
de nosotros se alinea y que no apoye
todas las políticas del partido
republicano o solo las posiciones
conservadores generales creo que
podríamos ir en cualquier dirección
pensé que tú estarías aquí solo Porque
cuando pienso en y no me refiero a un
conservador típico pero cuando pienso en
un conservador creo que defiende la
religión los valores tradicionales
Eso suena bien muy bien
todos somos Pro armas cierto y a favor
de la libertad de expresión pensamos
igual podemos pasar a otras políticas
bien Cómo te sientes con el tema del
aborto bueno siento que van a ocurrir
abortos peligrosos y se legalizan no
quiero entrar en un porcentaje pequeño
que lo es pero hay algunos
determinativos en los que la madre
morirá y luego también hay otros en los
que si haces que el aborto sea ilegal
utilizarán perchas es muy triste pero es
verdad y si no contamos los casos
extremos dirías que en su mayoría creo
que mantener la vida así A menos que
vaya a dañar una vida como la de la
madre o la del bebé si va a nacer y
puedes predecir que va a estar bien
entonces deberíamos mantener vivos a los
niños Supongo que para mí como dije he
ido y venido y no quiero estar a favor
pero Actualmente estoy a favor del
aborto no creo que nadie quiere estar a
favor Así que no es algo fácil de querer
hacer creo que el control de finalidad
Debería ser gratuito yo apoyo el control
de la natalidad gratuito creo que habría
disminuido drásticamente los abortos
pero pienso que también tenemos que
pensar en el después en la agencia de
adopción creo que debemos arreglar eso Y
creo que debemos abogar más para que las
mujeres jóvenes conozcan cuáles son sus
opciones quería mencionar esto todos se
sienten más del tipo intervencionista o
es algo así como aislacionista o incluso
como algo intermedio crees que
deberíamos entrarnos primero en los
problemas de nuestro país o qué piensas
estoy de acuerdo cómo vamos a ayudar a
otros países Cuando tenemos otras cosas
en el exterior quiero decir cuánto
dinero acabamos de enviar a Ucrania por
qué
no tiene que ver con nosotros hubiera
sido mejor que se invirtiera en el país
sí estamos priorizando eso y ni siquiera
podemos cuidar de nuestra propia gente
los veteranos se mueren de hambre en la
calle siento que deberíamos hacer algo
al respecto pero no podemos porque nos
enfocamos en otros países en lugar de
nosotros se sienten diferentes con su
posición ahora deberíamos cambiar
realmente me concentro en este conjunto
como si él tuviera más valores
conservadores tradicionales que yo
también pienso como tú nos cambiaría
ahora creo que lo que yo vi es que
pareces mucho más apasionada y fuiste
más franca tú pareces un poco más
tranquilo entonces al inicio dije sabes
qué eres la número dos pero ahora que
escucho más opiniones estaría de acuerdo
en cambiarlo
Qué valores tienen que sienten que no se
ajustan al valor conservador tradicional
o a los valores conservadores en general
estoy en contra del muro porque soy
universitario creo que la mayoría de las
personas que vienen no vienen a lastimar
a la gente vienen a ganarse la vida De
hecho estoy a favor del muro pero no
porque quiere mantener a la gente fuera
completamente sino porque quiero saber
quién viene a este país en el buen
sentido el tráfico sexual en general
viene a través de nuestra frontera Sur
al igual que las drogas Esa es la única
razón por la que lo apoyo Si la gente
quiere venir aquí a emigrar muy bien
estoy 100% en contra de la inmigración
ilegal Así que estoy a favor del muro
pero no es solo el muro son las personas
que vienen aquí y se quedan más tiempo
que sus visas ellos también tienen que
irse mi posición es única porque emigré
de México cuando era más joven y
probablemente no estaría aquí si no
fuera por eso pero realmente creo que la
inmigración ilegal es solo eso y legal
Ahora les pediré que tomen sus teléfonos
e ingresen a política al compass.org
y tomen la prueba de la brújula política
[Música]
creo que fue muy bueno en el quinto
puesto tenemos a maui
y luego en el cuarto tenemos a Cameron
[Música]
bien Yo pensé que estaría en el lugar 2
o 3 tenemos a Kelly en el tercer lugar
número uno
en el segundo puesto tenemos a Navy y en
el primero a Hunter
no esperaba subir tanto verdad esto es
como está bien digo Oye
la forma en que se enmarca esta prueba
de la brújula política evoca ciertas
reacciones Así que no abarcan mis puntos
de vista Pero sí alguno está sorprendido
no sería tercera o segunda con toda
energía pensé que iba a estar allí Sí
algunas de esas preguntas nunca las
había pensado antes me imagina que
estaría en algún lugar por aquí como
cuatro o cinco después de escucharlos a
todos saben creo que es raro que yo sea
el número uno y soy un hombre alto
blanco y hetero el hombre perfecto si
hay alguien que está mirando esto y no
está de acuerdo conmigo ni con la
opinión política de nadie más Por favor
míranos como personas todos tenemos
defectos Solo quiero que la gente vea
que podemos salvar Esta división solo
siendo humanos el uno con el otro Así
que solo difundan amor a todos